[Musique]
je suis nadia l'immédiat ni l'événement
auquel je vous convie à un voyage
fabuleux en orient qui aura lieu les 2
et 3 octobre sur la commune du
perray-en-yvelines
en week end vous allez pouvoir
comment dire voyager en orient alors on
va commencer par une conférence à 15h30
autour de la calligraphie et de
l'histoire de l'écriture arabe on aura
accès également à un compteur qui est
mandaté par l'institut du monde arabe
qui sera là pour nous conter une
histoire des mille et une nuits
[Musique]
à 19h30 le restaurant sera ouvert on
servira alors un méchoui et un couscous
traditionnel
pendant que un groupe de musiciens
jouera des musiques
orientales mais aussi des musiques
chantées par des occidentaux mais qui
sont très imprégné par la culture la
culture arabe le temps que la danseuse
se prépare et qu'elle nous fasse trois
passages très très sympa vous pourrez
aussi danser avec elle
[Musique]